hello welcome to this video playing van
input on finding button yeah so let's
see what we get I'm playing the cop off
system you have this is dangerous for
white castles is very dangerous check so
okay I'm going to play a play for soon
for made now yeah I mean you know if you
cannot just spend 19 seconds for all
that and just be probably totally dozed
anyway um I really shouldn't think about
this anymore and so Queens you five
maybe or something and preen h5 coming
alright f4 Queen age six should win what
what's the deal Queen age five how are
you not checkmated and so don't see it
check
checkmate yeah okay I think this is the
just punishment for this stuff I mean
Castle this already pretty substantial
mistake as after age five this attack is
very dangerous I've analyzed this for
that mentioned video series and why
should just not do it this is very
dangerous for him and especially in
blitz chess you should avoid it after h4
there's really just g5 and yeah it's
it's just an attack okay play d4 and
chatter split seconds taking them no I
don't think you can avoid this engine
what does the engine say minus one well
that's still pretty nice for what ok
this is made them f2f takes it's bad for
white but not losing a straightaway
something like that that I can I mean
it's a nice position but it's not made
this ideas and after this white is just
checkmated I wonder how the engine still
keeps minus two what does it do here for
18 h 5 king f2 we i run for it and this
is just minus 2 ok yeah the way it was
it was made cannot avoid it check them
and now made us unavoidable it's not we
have I can discuss your name we get made
yeah this is a line here that can be
recommended and it's pretty it's pretty
easy to play and yeah why should not
castle i think i have got rock group b 1
is what i suggest in my in my repertoire
just wait with the with castling until
black has committed somehow too yeah to
castling himself or that age five is not
coming
okay well thanks for watching